bonjour à toutes et à tous je m'adresse
à vous parce que je suis candidat à
l'élection législative du mois de juin
prochain sur la 7ème circonscription du
bas-rhin s'avère une sérieuse si je
tiens à présenter ma candidature c'est
parce que quelques dix ans je n'investis
aux côtés de nos concitoyens et pour les
représenter à l'assemblée nationale et
je souhaite pouvoir poursuivre cette
action afin de les représenter cette
circonscription a énormément d'alcool où
elle a à la fois des activités
industrielles des emplois industriels
long très très long vol plus que la
moyenne nationale par voie de
conséquence aussi un taux de chômage
plus faible qui surtout aussi une
activité économique artisanale
touristique eux extrêmement développé et
enfin aussi un tissu associatif
extrêmement dynamique je souhaite
évidemment pouvoir accompagner le
développement du dessous territoire et
je souhaite pouvoir le faire au sein
d'un mouvement politique qui est celui
de l'union de la droite et du centre
parce que je crois que plus que jamais
au titre délégué du cac et de ses alliés
il est essentiel de pouvoir offrir une
alternative à la map chroniques et aux
extrêmes et c'est tous les objets aussi
du combat qui nous met donc
collectivement pour faire en sorte que
nous ayons un groupe indépendant et fort
à l'assemblée nationale à très bientôt
et merci
[Musique]